[Music]
you are an independent film darling
especially you know your most recent one
thor ragnarok
but tell me what why is it so important
to support independent ohm in your words
and what is it done for you well I mean
you know I've got to make for with Tycho
ytt who is of course is an independent
filmmaker I mean you know we all are
storytellers and that's what we want to
do and and it's really there's no
difference in the sense of what you do
you just do it on a different scale but
it's incredibly important for me to
continue to make any film and to support
those communities you know it's
important to see these films opening
weekend to make sure that they really
have legs that they get into more
theatres because we want to have you
know representation and the kind of
stories that we tell we want to we want
to be able to see movies that reflect
the world that we live in and and also
project ideas of the world we can live
in and a lot of that work is being done
in independent film absolutely and for a
lot of people this award show kind of
launches into a lot more for them so
what is a piece of advice that you wish
you had when you were starting out oh
goodness
probably just to enjoy it I think you
know along the lines of you saying that
we had fun it to me it's like it's it's
such an incredible gift to get to do
what we do you know it really is and and
I don't take it for granted so I think
just taking a minute to really to really
enjoy it you're mentioning
representation and I want to talk about
Valkyrie for a minute because what she's
she's done for so many people is so
incredible and you had recently said
that she was by what has been the
reaction with that even given that the
scene was cut from the film well you
know the reaction from the BI community
has been incredible I mean I think we're
continuing to see more and more
representation in movies across the
board yeah you know it's it's been
incredible and Marvel is also fantastic
and you know and wanting and wanting to
tell nuanced stories and have all sorts
of superheroes and so I'm really I'm
excited to work with the studio that
wants to continue to grow I'm very in
love with her and I need to see her with
rocket immediately so
I get so happy to being like I like her
yeah right oh my gosh
but now I can't unthinkable
[Music]
you